hello my name is elizabeth i'm the
creative director of skull and bones and
i'm here to break down the skullenbones
ubisoft forward trailer this could be
the greatest heist ever
in skill and bones as you explore the
world and rise your infamy through epic
novel battles you will loot and unlock a
large variety of vanity sets that you
can complete or all mix to create a
unique look for your pirate captain and
ship
in our game you can also customize the
look of your crew this customization
currently changes as a set and not yet
individually
our game has a wide variety of weapons
for you to customize and here are some
quick examples of a few different types
of weapons like spike culverin keronade
and longan
longall for example offers long distance
shots but requires precision while the
karo knight provides very quick reload
speed but less damage output
each of those weapons have some element
damage type which has bodices and
minuses to different armor types of 4
enemies
that's a ballista it's commonly equipped
as a bow of your ship and shoots a
singular long-range high damage arrow at
a time
like all weapons in our game it can be
upgraded and has several elemental types
like fire piercing and even healing
and you kali will play the villain those
sails belong to the dutch merchant
company what i can say about this
faction is that their fleets transport
the most valuable cargo through the
dangerous waters of indian ocean that
faction can spot any ganks of parrots
from a long distance and eat multiple
ships at the same times with their
deadly mortars
historically parrots did transform their
ship to outsmart preys bigger than them
they could break walls below the deck as
an example or balance the oil to improve
the stability of a ship
so the system of armor is our
interpretation of how parrots can put
together a ship based on their enemy
strengths
every weapon and damage type will have
an armor that can counter it
so each armor is efficient at protecting
your hull and cargo from specific
faction techniques in our game we have
three main categories of ship
cargo navigation and combat the cargo
ships give you advantage in terms of
weight capacity the navigation ships are
faster and easier to maneuver while the
combat ship come with more cannon ports
which allows players to equip more
weapons and deal more damage
our ships also have a cool figure heads
that you can choose to equip you will be
able to find them throughout the game as
part of your progression or buy them in
our store guard your loins
pets are also confirmed for the game at
lunch you will find them as part of your
progression but you can also discover
the vanity sets for them as you progress
and through our store and seize that
[ __ ] convoy
attacking fort in our game is risky
business as part of the force defenses
they will send up a signal flare when
the gatekeepers spot a danger as the
reason
this is their way of calling for
reinforcements players will expect a
fleet of enemy ships coming towards them
and they will have to make the choice of
either fleeing or staying to fight for
the plunder
the longer you'll resist waves of
enemies the bigger the bounty will be
for you taking destiny is calling
rocket launchers can also be equipped on
our ships as secondary weapons it is one
of my favorite weapons because it works
better in a fast-paced naval battle as
it has a wide trajectory and allows
projectiles to its moving targets for
more efficiency compared to a single
shot weapon
so as you can see these are not your
modern day target lock torpedoes that
you will find in our game
the torpedoes we have usually have a
very long range but the accuracy may not
be as great as other weapons however
it's really fun to use
like mentioned before with our weapon
counter system you can equip certain
armor to increase your defense against
such weapons different weapons inflict
one of the different types of damage
explosive pursing fire flooding
crushing tearing or blunt
each type can result in immense damage
all our damage depending on your open
ensemble material
thank you for watching ubisoft forward
and we can't wait for you to save the
seas with us this november 8th